hi everyone I'm Steve and I'm so glad to
be back at aura dev this is my favorite
conferences in the world and even the
ones I haven't attended watching the
talks like really had a big impact on me
in my career so I'm real psyched to be
here with you all today this is a talk
called rust in production I'm assuming
that if you are attending a talk named
rust in production you probably know
what rust is but just on the off chance
that you don't rest is a programming
language that I am lucky enough to get
to work on as my job so I work at
Mozilla rust is largely sponsored by
Mozilla but actually has a lot of other
people working on it as well and so this
talk is also maybe slightly different
than you might expect this isn't about
me running rust in production this is
about other people running rust in
production we often treat rust even
though it's a programming language like
it's a product and so being on the core
team of rust my job is to help support
people who are using the language for
whatever tasks they're using it for and
we actually have regular meetings with
production users to like ask them what
their pain points are and if we can do
anything to help them and kind of that
sort of supporting role so I'm going to
be talking about other people's success
stories using rust and you know what
they use it for and all those kinds of
things there's two sort of other reasons
why I wanted to give this talk they're
sort of related to that one is just the
I'm sort of like an amateur rust
historian I rust has a very long and
interesting and complicated history as a
project it's almost 8 years old at this
point actually even though it's only
been production ready for about two of
those eight years and so I gave a talk
for the ACM a while back on sort of the
pre 1.0 ancient rust but I like to think
that I'm just chronicling as it develops
how it goes because I think those
stories are very very interesting so
some of this is sort of a snapshot of
rust at this particular moments and some
of it is also because a lot of people
tell me that they're very excited about
rust and interested but they don't know
what to actually do with it like there's
a lot of people who are like rust seems
really cool I really like everything
about it but I don't know what to do so
some of my motivation for telling these
stories is to show you all the various
different things that people are using
rust for and maybe you'll find that
actually it is applicable to the things
that you do at your job
one of the reasons why people have this
kind of issue with rust is that we are
in a really weird space as a language so
rust is simultaneously an incredibly
low-level language that lets you do
absolutely as low-level tasks as you
need to do I have a hobby project or
work on building an operating system and
rust for example but most people don't
use rust as a low-level language they
use it as a sort of higher-level
language that lets them go low when they
want to so you have sort of a lot of
high-level level features like iterators
and other things that you would sort of
expect some people have described us as
being sort of like a statically typed
scripting language feel a lot of the
time and so you do this like high level
work really often since I work on rust
now I'm obviously a little biased but
like I write rust even for things I used
to write Ruby scripts for and that's
like totally feasible to do in rust so
this we don't want to say that rust is
super high level because then people
don't even use it for low level things
but if we advocate it for only low level
things people are like I don't write
kernel drivers as my day job so cool I
can totally ignore it so it's sort of a
little a little challenging so this is
what I want to sort of show off these
like broad breadth of things that people
are using stuff for so the structure of
this talk is basically I'm going to
start off by talking a little bit about
what production ready actually means
because I think that's an interesting
question and then I'm gonna talk about a
couple of companies and I have them in
sort of a vague order that I think makes
sense but there's a lot of them and
that's you know a little complicated so
we're gonna talk about different people
that are that are using rest in
production and why and it sort of is
more detailed at the start and then kind
of gets a little less detailed towards
the end and then finally right at the
end I have a recommendation about if
you're trying to introduce rust to your
company how do you go about doing so
that's sort of the overall structure of
this talk okay so this question was
extremely relevant to me when we were
releasing rust 1.0 because people were
talking about this but like you know
we're like okay rust 1.0 means that it's
backwards compatible and therefore it's
ready to be used in production and a lot
of people were asking like before rust
1.0 happened like when is rust
production ready like I want to start
in production but I think that this
question we say it like it's a singular
thing but it's actually a complicated
multifaceted kind of question the most
important thing is context so I think
rust is definitely production-ready in
certain areas and definitely not
production-ready in other areas so
without knowing like production ready
for what it's really hard to say like is
a blanket statement whether or not this
is something you know that's actually
true so I'm really into like qualifying
statements as opposed to making blanket
statements I think this is important one
aspect of this is this thing called
crossing a chasm
I don't know if any of you familiar with
this book it sort of was like the hot
saying in the business world in like
1990 or 1991 or something it's an entire
book but I'm basically just gonna tell
you the whole premise because it's not
actually that complicated
so basically crossing the chasm is a
model of how technologies get adopted so
the idea is that there's these different
populations of people and you sort of
fit into one of these different groups
additionally I actually think that
people fit into them differently per
technology so there's like the
innovators the early adopters the early
majority the late majority and the
laggards and the name crossing the chasm
comes because if you can get the
innovators and early adopters to use
your thing a lot of technologies die
before they become mainstream and
there's this like gap where it's
difficult to go from a thing that
hobbyists and enthusiasts use to things
that businesses and people actually use
and so it's sort of my job to convince
you that rust is like here on the curve
that we've like made it over that gap
and that that's where we are last time I
gave a presentation similar to this the
arrow was like exactly on the line of
like just over the chasm so we moved a
little bit there's sort of definitions
about what each of these cohorts kind of
mean but like basically innovators are
people that just love technology for its
own sake and are very interested in it
early adopters are people that want to
do stuff but aren't afraid to use
something that's maybe not totally ready
yet and in the early majority and the
late majority are kind of the people
that wait until a technology is like
proven out by these early adopters to be
like a good technology they would want
to actually use so I was in sort of the
like late majority with Ruby Ruby is
what I did before rust basically I came
to it relatively late and it was already
a well-established technology by then
but I was an innovator in rust like
adopted it well before like it was Eddy
ready for any of these kinds of things
and I think that a lot of times when we
argue about the quality of different
technologies it's actually because we're
talking about I am someone who is
enthusiastic and want to be an early
adopter of this but you or someone who
is skeptical and maybe is a laggard and
so it's like recognizing that these
things are different and I think that's
where a lot of arguing on the internet
comes from is like different people have
different places they put themselves on
this chart so why do I think that we're
past this chasm we have this page we
call our production users page the
Friends page so these are the friends of
rust
these are all organizations that are
using rust in production they're the
actual website if you go to it it
Scrolls way down so we actually
randomized the companies on the page
every time you refresh it you get a
different order and so there's about a
hundred companies on there right now
that are actively using rust in
production and there's there's some that
are using it that are not on the page -
and I'll get to that in a little bit but
it's kind of significant use by people
you know a lot of people think that
since rust came from Mozilla it was like
a Mozilla only technology but a lot of
companies are actually using rust for a
very wide variety of things one way that
you can sort of think about is this
ready for me or not is through packages
so with rust we invested very early on
in building a package manager and a
package management system so that people
could develop modules and distribute
them to each other in an open-source way
and it's been really fun to watch these
numbers just like go up so I took the
screen shot yesterday so to date we've
had 247 million downloads of packages in
all time and we have about 12,000
packages in existence and so that's
really cool but this also kind of ties
into the question of like is rust ready
for your production use I find that I am
productive and rust when there's enough
packages in the ecosystem I'm working in
to get things done but if I have to
re-implement everything myself it goes
much much
so one example of this is in the sort of
web development area we've been working
a lot on web development and rust over
the last year and so there are a lot of
packages but there's no like consensus
as to which one is winning yet so it's
like here 25 different web frameworks
enjoy picking which one of them you want
to use so maybe that's an area where
we're not quite super mature yet and so
diving into crates Ohio is a great way
to sort of figure out like okay is there
going to be code that I can build off of
and like is this something that is you
know useful for me however as much as I
love to to my own horn about these
download numbers I think it's important
to place them in context NPM is arguably
the largest package manager in the world
and you'll notice I was saying we had 12
million downloads lifetime MPM 28 day
download number is about 10 billion so
we're definitely you know relatively
small if you look at crates toyou relish
to this we're there so there's still
lots of room to grow and you know
there's lots of things going on and so
yeah so I think it's also important to
you know it's not like we got a lot of
stuff for a young language but like not
a lot of stuff in like the grand scheme
of things okay so that's enough meta
shenanigans about this question about
what production means and sort of a
little bit of that background I'm
actually going to talk more about NPM as
a segue because they were actually one
of the companies that is now using rust
in production and is actually growing
their production usage of rust so NPM
specifically that falls a little small
I'm sorry MPM specifically is using rust
for the services on the registry so NPM
is the package manager for JavaScript if
you're not a JavaScript person it's sort
of the crates i/o of Java scripts and so
there's the the stuff that runs on the
server that manages you know where the
packages are actually stored and
permissions and like all that kind of
stanag ins and so they've built it in
sort of a micro-services architecture so
they've written some micro services in
rust and are adding more in the future -
specifically power the registry and one
of the things that CJ their CTO says and
why she really appreciates rust as a
technology
is I like rust because it's boring and
that's not normally the story that you
wanted of like we're a new programming
language we're super boring but what I'm
what she means by this is like
operationally rust is very boring so the
services that they've built in rust it
took them a little while to get them to
compile if you've ever tried programming
and rust you may know this like little
dialogue that you have with a compiler
that is very strict about what it lets
you do and doesn't do I was like to joke
that some people say that it's fighting
with a compiler but I don't really think
it's fighting I think it's like a friend
who's telling you you're about to do
something stupid and you probably
shouldn't and that's like a friendly
relationship not like an adversarial one
but anyway because of those strict like
safety restrictions and because of
several other things I'm gonna get into
in a minute for NPM Russ is very
operationally boring they deploy the
service and then it works and they don't
it doesn't like knock over the server or
like have problems like when they need
to add more features they do it and they
deploy it and then they forget about it
until they need to do more stuff and
that's a really appealing thing about
Russ to them it's sort of said like like
like you can come to rest for the
liability but you can also stay for low
memory usage so this is an area where we
are slowly coming to realize rust use is
the fact that Russ isn't ahead of time
compiled language and does not have a
virtual machine or anything means that
it's resource usage is very small which
matters if you're doing things like
embedded devices or whatever but if
you're talking about like a server-side
thing it means you get more for your
money like AWS bill is often one of the
biggest costs that a new companies have
and so low resource usage isn't
necessarily about low-power devices it's
about making more out of the dollars
that you spend on your hardware so to
give you an example
crystal IO is actually written and rust
on the back end it's actually a rust
back end in an ember j/s front end but
it uses last I checked about thirty five
megabytes of RAM resident at all times
and it just doesn't grow it doesn't
shrink it's just 35 Meg's and again I
coming from Ruby like 25 Meg's is the
overhead of a Ruby interpreter and if
you want to start up our rails process
you're looking at like three
Meg's easily so you're talking like 1/10
of the size of a rails app which means
that you need to pay Heroku a lot less
money than you would for an interpreted
technology so this is something that
we're slowly coming to appreciate
several people that have considered
using rust instead of the JVM have said
things similar like the JVM is great
it's a masterpiece of technology but it
needs so much RAM to do its job whereas
rust gives you this ability to have low
memory usage so that's kind of an
interesting aspect of this and sort of
related we often talk about rust with
this like memory safety thing and that's
because before rust hit 1.0 and was like
production-ready the people that were
into it were programming language
enthusiasts and so we like to talk about
programming language features but that's
not about like what you can do with
those features which is what's more
interesting to people who are not into
programming languages so it's not really
like memory safely strictly speaking
it's that rust encourages correctness
and maintainability over time rust
strengths really come in large code
bases that are kind of old and
maintaining those over time and so it's
really hard to see sometimes when you
get started and you write a little
program there was a thread on the forums
the other day that was like does this
need to be this for both and it's like
yes and no like the point is is that you
know we're exposing all the air
conditions to you and you do have to
handle them and that means that it's a
little more verbose but that means when
you put it into production you know
you've handled all the air conditions
and so that's kind of where we see rusts
strengths and so yeah low resources
usage and simple ops are icing on the
cake and I bring this up in the context
of NPM because they've said that but
this is also something that recursion
umber of these other production users
that we've talked to so yeah that's a
theme second company is Mozilla I am
employed by Mozilla to work on rusts and
it's great but I figure pretty much
everybody wants to know about Mozilla
using rust so I just put it up next as
like let's get that one out of the way
and then move on to the stuff that maybe
you haven't heard as much about so why
did Mozilla invest in rust basically a
long time ago when Mozilla was starting
up a research and development division
they were like what are some projects
that we
be useful for accomplishing Missoula's
mission that maybe need a little bit of
R&D and employee there had been working
on rust as his own programming language
in his spare time and basically said I
think that we can make Firefox better by
making a programming language that is
significantly better than C++ which is
mostly what Firefox is written in and
and that will allow us to do cool stuff
and so they said cool and like that's
why Mozilla invested in rust in general
as for Firefox and I'm super happy to
see I don't know if you have been aware
of this news there's been a lot of
marketing about this lately but Firefox
57 is coming out in a like a week eight
days or something and we're calling it
Firefox quantum because it's super fast
quantum thing a lot of people are like
that's not what quantum means it's like
but it's a quantum is about like a
discrete step and so what what quantum
is I actually think Mozilla does a bad
job of advertising what quantum does
quantum is basically taking all of these
projects that we've been doing research
on ripping the thing the old things out
of Firefox and putting the new things
into them so Firefox is now 2 times
faster than Firefox 32 was which Firefox
is kind of known for being slow these
days so it's kind of like alright but
people have been saying like this feels
faster than chrome now and this is
actually due to a lot of work not just
in rusts there's actually been a ton of
things that are all going into 57 so if
you're not a Firefox user you should
definitely check it out next week it's
pretty fantastic one other last thing
before I talk about the rust parts of
quantum and like why that matters is
also in this rebrand they're doing like
a new logo for Firefox and over the
nightly courses 57 was developed they
actually were replacing the icon on a
near-daily basis so we had like the the
Firefox logo that was being used until
recently and then this Calvin and Hobbes
one and then this is Phoenix which is
what Firefox was called before it was
called Firefox and then that was the 1.0
Firefox logo and then there's a Doge
Firefox and then finally the nightly is
is sort of blue and then the fire
57 will have that logo so it's kind of
cool I kept like updating my nightly and
I was like where did my browser go like
when the Calvin and Hobbes thing land
huh what's going on so the part of
quantum that's in 57 in rust is called
stylo and stylo is basically rewriting
the way that firefox handles CSS
entirely in rust so that c++ code was
160,000 lines of code and now it's 85
thousand lines of rust code this is it's
called stylo because it was taken out of
the servo project which is another
browser that we're building entirely in
rust from the ground up and so rusts
relationship to firefox quantum is
basically like rip out chunks of servo
toss them in Firefox and like make it
better and so we're not like rewriting
Firefox in rust immediately like it's
like 9 million lines of code or
something you don't just like do that
overnight so it's about slow and steady
transition away and so a lot of people
are like okay so you rewrote it of
course it's better what does like rust
specifically have to do like oftentimes
the rewrite is better because you know
the constraints better and all these
other things there were actually two
different attempts previously at
improving the styling handling in gecko
and specifically in paralyzing it so one
of the big advantages that stylo brings
is that all of your CSS is handled in
parallel so there's like lots of threads
and they do cool stuff there were
actually two previous attempts in the
last six years to do this in C++ and
both of them ended up failing and so
rust safety guarantees really strongly
help with parallel code and so if you
need to do something that has sort of
you know this kind of stuff it can be
very very helpful Josh Mathews who is
actually a research engineer who works
on servo gave a presentation at Russ
Bell Trust recently in the next two
screenshots I have or of slides of his
these are a conversation he had in the
IRC room or is basically like one of the
best parts about stylo has been how much
easier it's been to implement these
style optimizations because of rust
specifically and they're like can you
imagine if we needed to do this in C++
in the time frame that we have here
and so like Russ is able to ship these
features better and faster and the
second quote is it's so rare that we get
fuzzing bugs in rust code especially
considering all the complicated stuff
that we're doing I can't remember
getting a fuzzing bug from the style
system before but now I'm not doing it
anymore
the last thing on that quote was like
you guys sound like a commercial um but
like this is why Mozilla has invested so
heavily is that we really believe that
it's going to make Firefox like the best
web browser it's just taking a little
time to get there ok enough about my job
the next company that I want to tell you
about is Dropbox and the reason I picked
Dropbox is they've actually been using
rusts before it was technically
production ready in production like they
basically like they worked on it
previously and then they shipped after
1.0 but they had been working on it even
before then
and so Dropbox specifically their job is
syncing and sending files this is their
new logo and so they rewrote the way
that they determine what bytes go on
what hard drives in rust which is like
the lowest level and most core part of
their business has been running on rust
for about a year and a half now it was
actually in rust for about six months
before they told anybody so it's kind of
funny because they they wanted to be
like we flipped the switch six months
ago and none of you noticed that's how
you know it's working and so there was
this like real tense period where I was
like man I really want to tell people
that Dropbox is using rust right now but
I gotta wait and can't tell them and
that's kind of was kind of silly and
frustrating but this is what what
Dropbox is doing and they're they're
increasingly investing in rust so that's
on the servers but they're talking about
maybe putting some stuff in a client so
you'll actually have rust running the
Dropbox client and that's really cool
one of the things I forgot to mention is
the like with Firefox having such a
large install base having rust run on
all those computers is really cool like
I'm motivated by people using the stuff
that I write and so the idea that like a
programming language I work on is now
running code in like hundreds of
millions of computers is like kind of
mind-boggling and really awesome this is
a reddit comment I'm not gonna read you
all this because reading a large thing
is fun but this is the guy who is the
main technical lead at Dropbox working
on this stuff and he sucks a little bit
of
specifically why they did this we have a
short list of minor grievances and a
very very short list of major ones build
times so we still one of West's
weaknesses at the moment is that our
builds are not that fast this has been
an area that we've been putting a lot of
time into just to throw in a little bit
of you know it's not all just totally
happy all the time I want to give you an
unbiased reason about using rust and
then that one of the things I'm really
proud about I sort of alluded to this
earlier it's worth adding the rust core
team has been amazingly friendly and
helpful so if you end up using rust in
production we on the rust team are
extremely interested in making you
successful and like go to the point of
even prioritizing features that we hear
that that people in production need and
to be added so we are super invested in
people using rusts stuff and really
happy that Dropbox was willing to work
with us in this capacity the next
company I chose because they are
sponsoring this conference
Atlassian you may have heard of them a
tiny little tiny little company
lasya know they're super huge they
recently updated this is a pull request
from a couple days ago to that Friends
page they were like we previously were
saying terabytes of data but it's
actually petabytes so sorry we're that
we're going to make this more impressive
and so they specifically are doing
processing on source code they have like
analytics and stuff that they run and so
they're turning through petabytes of
data using russ now so that's pretty
neat and the thing that I'm sort of
excited about there's a lot of companies
doing this kind of like processing stuff
and I think this is definitely one way
that rust fits in well too like
server-side web development is like
maybe you write the some of the front
end but like the front end of your back
end the thing that initially gets the
requests is in a high-level language
where you don't care and then you're
like serious crunching background jobs
are written and rust is a pattern that
we've seen a lot of people use and so
this is kind of similar like Atlassian
is not running their web properties on
rust but they're doing these sort of
like back-end tasks that's pretty neat
but I sort of also was a little like
they do stuff because they're not open
source so if you go to the elastance
github page and you search for rust you
get no hits and this is no
the thing that I think is kind of a
little interesting and sort of as the
theme of these next couple companies I'm
gonna talk to you about is that uh I've
been working in open source for a really
long time and so I just sort of assumed
that things are open-source because
that's just what I've been doing and
once you start having to support
customers who you know are not open
source companies sometimes you don't
really know exactly what it is they're
doing
so I'm gonna be a little a little sort
of high-level about these next couple
ones because they're all companies that
I like I don't totally know but I think
it's interesting the first one is the
government of Qatar they have this thing
called Q cert that's their like they
describe it as their Internet Security
Response Team and they say they're using
rust to do DNS analytics I don't know
what that means their code is definitely
not open-source but uh it's interesting
I'll leave it at that this is an
anonymous reddit comment so please take
it with that giant grain of salt this is
an anonymous reddit comment but this
person says that I work for a fortune
500 company and we have four full-time
devs working on a Russ project and we're
hoping to expand that next year who are
they I don't know but someone cool is
doing something and you know that's kind
of really interesting and exciting again
being motivated by you so you're kind of
like this is awesome
a similar kind of related thing that's
been popping up lately is companies are
not necessarily saying they're using
rust but they're like if you did know
rust that would be very helpful for this
job so Amazon has posted this job
listing and later we actually found out
that they just shipped their very first
chunk of rust in production and they
couldn't tell us what it was about but
they're starting to add a little bit
more and so they they kind of just slip
that in there briefly like by the way if
you knew some rusts that would
definitely be a plus in this job and
that's also sort of become an
interesting thing for rust enthusiasts a
lot of times people sort of take an
interest in an emerging technology is a
reason to hire you for a job even if
you're not actually doing specifically
rest stuff so for example Dropbox
doesn't hire rust developers they hi
developers and they sort of expect them
to work on the go or the Python or the
rust that they use this is also a way
that companies have been using rust to
is sometimes like it's weird to be like
there's a hundred companies in
production but if you look at explicit
rust jobs there's like twelve posts at
any given time and that's because a lot
of companies are sort of using their
existing programmers are starting to
write rust code and or they're hiring
for a broader position than specifically
rust stuff there's kind of little weird
that there's like all these companies
but not that many explicit jobs yet
we'll get there another similar slightly
mysterious company that makes a similar
claim is like CloudFlare and they said
that they have their javascript
performance team needs people and that
knowing rust would be beneficial so I
don't know what that means either
but again a similar big like cloud for
likes talked about how much they're like
a giant percentage of the Internet and
so we'll see what happens with them the
next one is Facebook actually so I do
know a little bit more about Facebook
this is where I'm sort of transitioning
away from the companies I don't know
anything about Facebook has started
using rust they specifically use
mercurial for all of their source code
handling and they rewrote a mercurial
server in rust and they actually use it
I don't think they're using it to host
like the crown jewel source code yet but
it's a thing they're actively working on
and they're sponsoring a lot of rust
conferences so this is a sticker that
they were giving out at rust belt rust
which is one of the rest conferences
that happens every year and they were a
big sponsor and they were handing out
these stickers and they were like we
definitely want to do more rust to have
more people come do stuff at Facebook so
that's really cool I've conflicted
feelings about Facebook but like a big
giant company using my work is I'll take
it somebody when I tweeted this picture
somebody replied to me notice the rust
logo is gone like don't let Facebook eat
rust because they've been doing that
with programming languages lately so
we'll see another tiny little startup
you may have heard of as Microsoft
they're not really explicitly using rust
yet this one's like a semi reach but a
Visual Studio code is now all of the
search functionality is entirely powered
by rip grip which is a tool written in
rust and I think this is kind of cool
for a number of reasons first of all
a Visual Studio code is a really great
product in my opinion I actually have
like halfway switched away from vim -
Visual Studio code which is the thing I
never thought I would ever say like I'm
switching from vim to a Microsoft
product but but the other funny thing
about this is that they just because
Visual Studio code is written in
electron and uses NPM to distribute all
their stuff they put rip grep support in
vs code by making an NPM package that
doesn't have JavaScript source code in
it it has precompiled rust binaries and
then that's how they put the rust into
BS code so that's kind of a little weird
and interesting but they're like using
NPM for that instead of cargo well it
works this kind of needs another company
you may have heard of Oracle a similar
theme of like you know all right it's
Oracle but they do a lot of stuff that's
cool they recently joined the open
container initiative and they're
actually have written a container
runtime that corresponds with that open
definition of what a container is and
they specifically believe that rust is
going to be a great thing for writing
containers in and doing that kind of
work this is sort of next little theme
I'm going into is ops and container
stuff so it's cool and it's open source
surprisingly and so that's kind of a
neat thing they're doing core OS another
big name in the container space they
don't use a ton of rust yet but they're
they're some of the tools that are
included in core OS is distribution that
they put on their containers is
implemented in rust and they also have
some internal only services that they
write rust Ginetta gets in so that's
pretty cool another fun thing I used to
be a teacher I actually taught Ruby
professionally for a long time and I
kind of still sometimes wish I was
actually doing teaching is Coursera so
this is from a blog post they wrote
Coursera is a MOOC the massively online
whatever teaching platform I forget what
the letters mean but uh you can submit
homework problems in whatever so say
you're taking a scala course you submit
your homework to their servers your
scala files and that actually will build
and run and test their stuff so they
need to make sure like there
accepting arbitrary code from random
people on the internet and that is
definitely not the safest thing in the
world so they have this complicated
docker setup that I guess this picture
describes but the interesting part is
they specifically have rust code running
inside of docker so your your homework
solutions are tested inside of like
what's almost a container inside of
docker that's written in rust that like
verifies like okay you were not breaking
out of this container by restricting
syscalls and doing all that other kind
of like low-level work so that's pretty
interesting instead of being a whole
container they just like docker plus
some rest code it's that's neat
next time buddies habitat which is
actually chef if you remember chef they
sort of have habitat as their new
product and they're sort of going all-in
on it they kind of say habitat instead
of chef even though it's Jeff and it's
an ops deployment thing that's entirely
written in rust and they've actually
done a great deal of like supporting the
rust ecosystem they sponsored some
conferences and they might even sponsor
development of rust itself habitat is
kind of cool because I don't fully get
it exactly but instead of there being
like a server that tells where your
services need to go you bundle the
configuration with your app and it
travels that way
I don't know Ops is not my specialty but
that bundling stuff is all written in
rust and so you would like to ploy a
rails app with some rust code wrapped
around it I'm just kind of neat and then
finally in my ops category is the link
Rd folks so link Rd is not the name of
the company it's the name of the product
link Rd itself is written in Scala not
in rust but they have a extension that's
linker D TCP that is a rust plugin for
linker D and they're super heavily
investing in the rust ecosystem I'm
actually extremely thankful they've
hired a number of prominent open-source
rust developers and paid them to work on
open source projects and they're
continuing to sort of make the rust
Network stack be like a world-class sort
of thing so that's really cool and
exciting so that's the last ops company
I have for you
alright I'm sort of winding down getting
to the end here
Baiju xlab is a company that I was like
ok what's that there's this thing called
Intel SGX I don't know if any of you
have heard of this or not it's this
thing that's sort of like you know Apple
with the touch ID they're like don't
we definitely don't send your
fingerprints to the government it's
stored on this chip on the phone that it
can't leave intel chips kind of have
this similar thing they call a secure
Enclave that like there's stuff running
on your laptop and you can't look at it
and either can anyone else and they
won't tell you why it's there sort of
like thing I don't really fully get it
but there's like an API to do that and
Bide UX lab is building rust tooling
that if you want to be able to like do
that stuff you use rust to do it uh so
like uh yeah I mean this is an Intel
computer so I don't know whatever but
yeah like Intel SGX
and so it's one of the only tool sets
you can use to do that stuff so that's
kind of neat finally on the list of
companies using rust I have a couple
more things after this but companies
using rust is cryptocurrencies I'm a big
cryptocurrency skeptic honestly I was
really into dogecoin because I think
that it's like silly and ridiculous and
that's what cryptocurrencies are kind of
a little silly and ridiculous but rust
has found this kind of weird niche in
cryptocurrencies where a lot of them are
using things now I don't know if you
heard about aetherium lately but they're
using rusts uh great yeah I don't know
today is not the best day to be like
yeah aetherium is using rust bugs can
happen even in any programming language
even ones that are built for reliability
you know logic errors occur but they're
definitely raising lots of money and
spending lots of money and doing it with
Russ stuff so that's cool even though
it's not personally what I'm into
I'm really glad like all of these
companies have sponsored multiple russ
conferences and have given a lot of like
resources back to the community that's
kind of neat
there's also a couple companies this is
a French company called clever cloud and
they're sort of like a Heroku like you
give us our source code we put it on
servers and manage it for you and while
they don't use a lot of rust internally
they have like explicit support for you
writing web services in rust and
deploying on their platform this is a
couple like support stuff that's growing
in that way now we're even if companies
don't use rust explicitly they're sort
of supporting you using rust on their
platform and that's kind
and then finally the last companies I
want to talk about our integer 32 and s
quería engineer 32 is a us-based company
and a square as a german company and
both of these are consultancies that
specialize in rust development so a lot
of people they are sort of when they
want to start doing production work in a
new technology they're like what happens
if there's a question I can't answer
what happens if I need some support or
whatever and so these are both companies
that you can give money to to do right
rust code for you if that's your thing I
think that's a sort of healthy part of a
growing ecosystem is having you know
entities that do this kind of work as I
said before if you have questions the
rust team is happy to answer you but if
you want to like pay someone to answer
your questions they will gladly take
your money
um managers like doing that sometimes
it's a valuable thing so this is kind of
also a neat a neat thing is seeing some
people you know be able to do rest
developments you know in that capacity
so those are that's today people using
rest today lately I've been really
really obsessed with webassembly
and I mean like really obsessed with
webassembly and this is an area where I
hope to see a lot of future production
work for rust this is not a web assembly
talks I'll get into all the details but
we on the rust team are increasingly
interested in web assembly and making
rust a great thing to write web assembly
stuff in so expect to see some news
about that and as web assembly grows I
hope that rust sort of becomes the
de-facto away and I expect to see web
assembly result in a whole new slew of
interesting things on the web and I
think that rust will be used in that
capacity in a pretty significant way
because there's a lot of advantages but
that's in the future and so I won't get
into that more right now but if you want
to talk about that afterwards I'd love
to talk about that stuff okay
that was kind of a quick overview of all
these things that people are doing with
rust and you know making money on it and
betting their companies on it before I
go I wanted to briefly mention that if
you're interested in doing putting rust
and like advocating for rust inside your
company one I would like to help you do
that but to Ashley Williams who's up
here in the front she came with me is
gave a great talk at rust fest Keith
last year on how she got NPM to start
using rust and it's a great talk on like
introducing stuff into your company like
don't tell them to rewrite everything
immediately that's never gonna work like
here's how to actually advocate for
things and I think that is broader than
just rust purely I think it's a great
way if you want to advocate for any
technology so you should check that out
and I won't repeat what she said so that
is all I have for you today thank you so
much
[Applause]